[Music]
hello you have maybe seen how we
recently struggled to decide which huge
and impressive generative model we would
like to cover next on the channel should
it be dali 2 from openai that can
generate or edit images from just text
or rather the slightly boring news about
a new largest large language model
called pathways language model or short
palm from google ai
we suppose you already guessed from the
title of this video that we decided to
go for pom we did not choose dali 2 for
the moment because we released a video
about diffusion models and glide way too
recently to deal again with that just
now maybe later so subscribe in this
video we will summarize the palm paper
for you it's
only 83 pages long
and we will explain what is so
interesting about this boring large
language model palm spoiler it can
explain jokes but miss coffee bean it's
not only about the jokes is it
but first let's thank weights and biases
for supporting us for this video how
many times did you crack a hard problem
and wanted to show your solution to
someone
well weights and biases reports have got
you covered if all your insights are in
a particular chart you can share it in a
report with a couple of quick comments
but if you have more to show reports can
also do a long form more polished piece
of analysis just check out this report
about dali mini it's like a blog post
but on steroids reports can help you
keep apart the things you want to share
and rather not share you can use reports
as a dashboard for reporting a smaller
subset of metrics than the main weights
and biases workspace but you can also
create private shareable links or public
view only links and share it with anyone
go to 1db dot me slash ai minus coffee
minus break to see more about how
reports can help you quickly share your
work with colleagues around the world
now back to boring large language models
when it comes to large language models
we have been bored lately we have been
bored by glam from google ai which has a
total of 1.2 trillion parameters but
don't be that impressed the model works
a lot with sparsity so it activates only
97 billion parameters at a time which is
only eight percent of the capacity of
the whole model and on the sparse model
landscape with trillions of parameters
we could also count wu dao 2.0 of
1.75 trillion parameters or google's
switch transformers of 1.6 trillion
parameters but let's take a look at
dense models shall we we have been
bothered by lambda from google ai which
is a
137 billion parameter model specialized
on dialogue
then with gopher from deepmind of 280
billion parameters and let's not forget
the largest monolithic model so far
called megatron turing energy from
microsoft and nvidia with
530 billion parameters okay and of
course google needed to claim the
biggest model again so they made palm
just a bit bigger just enough to
overshadow megatron by 10 billion
parameters so yeah they made a 540
billion parameter model and keep in mind
that this is a dense model all
parameters are used during inference
there's no sparsity here in terms of
model architecture palm does not
innovate it is a gpt-like dense
transformer decoder the beginning of the
text goes in the transformer predicts
the next word while attending to the
previous words the authors do use some
tricks for training this beast for
example they are computing attention and
the feed forward layer in parallel which
is what people from illusor ai have been
doing with gpt j6b
for example palm also uses sweetglue
activations rotary positional embeddings
and a special lossless vocabulary to
account for many languages in the
training data for code and for numbers
these things have already been proven to
help train large language models by
previous work and pom's innovation is
completely geared towards training this
beast efficiently
now what does it mean efficiently for
google it certainly does not mean the
same as it means for you when you are
happy when you parallelize your gpu
training on your four gpus your cluster
node has
for google this means and i hope you are
seated that they used 6144
tpu chips for training
wow just for comparison the most
impressive numbers so far were
established for megatron turing energy
on 2240
a100 gpus and for gopher which went up
to
4096 tpu version 3 chips
so how does it work how can this coffee
bean train on
6144 tpu chips too
well she can't but google could because
they used two tpu version 4 pods with
3072 chips each with fast
intercommunication each pod should have
a full copy of the model parameters
partitioned over the 3072 chips
now to let the two parts communicate
efficiently the authors use the pathways
system which was introduced by google in
a previous paper in a nutshell a batch
of training data is divided into half
and each half is sent to each pod for
forward and backward propagation then
the gradients on half the batch are
transferred to the other pod and vice
versa but this also means that the
transfer must wait until the other pot
finishes and when the waiting is
complete a burst in data transfer of 81
terabytes per second happens at a time
but you can imagine that all this
waiting means that in this time the
course cannot really compute interesting
stuff it's really impressive how through
a lot of engineering tricks miss coffee
bean has no idea about the authors
achieved an analytically computed
hardware flops utilization of over 50
percent which is impressive and
unprecedented by the way hardware flops
utilization basically measures the time
in which the hardware is not idled or
waiting for something but really
computes something interesting in this
table comparing palm to previous large
language models you can see a flops
utilization of 46.2 percent so smaller
than 57.8 percent in the caption
this is because in the table you can
find the flops utilization without
rematerialization rematerialization
means that one saves memory by not
storing some intermediate activations
but by recomputing them when needed this
means that with this whole recomputing
in rematerialization
the chips are busier when training pawn
than the other models are which are not
using the trick so for comparability you
can see the number in the table without
re-materialization
we see how high this is nonetheless a
lot higher than for the comparably
inefficient gpt3 model for example
okay we get it this thing is big it's
training fast so what is it eating
exactly
well it's feeding off lots and lots of
training data on 780 billion tokens to
be exact 50 of the data consists of
social media conversations in multiple
languages almost a quarter of the data
consists of filtered web pages then
books wikipedia news and code so already
from the training data we assume that
palm will have multilingual abilities
and will be able to do code completion
it used
gigabytes of source code in java html
javascript python php c-sharp xml c-plus
plus nc
and surprise surprise the model can do
code completion fixed compilation errors
translate code from one programming
language into the other even though its
pre-training data set contain 50 times
less code than codex 12b did which is a
dedicated code completion language model
the hypothesis here is that palm can do
code completion even though only five
percent of its training data consisted
of code because it benefits from its
size and its training on natural
language this natural language training
makes it more data efficient when it
comes to code data
on natural language palm improves
state-of-the-art uncommon benchmarks
like natural language inference where
one has to say whether a sentence
entails or contradicts another reading
comprehension question answering and
even on the complicated vinograd style
schemas and so on but we did not even
get to the jaw dropping part yet google
had previously organized the collection
of big bench which stands for beyond the
imitation game benchmark which contains
quite the tricky tasks like delivering
persuasive arguments for false
statements or finding the russian
proverb closest in meaning to a given
english proverb big bench is quite the
crazy collection of tasks where even the
average human has a 50 success rate
well by scaling palm from 8 billion to
62 billion to 500 billion parameters we
see how palm in fu shot learning
surpasses the average human
one word here maybe you are wondering
what few shot learning means well i
remember a time when future learning
could also mean that one trains a model
further on 10 maybe 100 samples and
updates the parameters of the model
while doing so with the feedback from
these few examples of course
catastrophic forgetting is a huge
problem here and the updates on the
little data can undo what a lot of
training have previously done
but there were parameter updates through
gradients but since gpt3 what we have
just described is rather called fine
tuning and the default meaning of
viewshot learning has shifted to
something else
the model receives a couple of solved
examples as a prompt which is
pre-appended to the input so we have
problem solution problem solution then
problem and then the gpt-like model
completes the sequence with the correct
examples as input since gpt3 we have
been used to expect large language
models to be sensitive to this kind of
prompting and give right answers even
without having any updates done on them
and we are a bit wondering why this is
called few shot learning when there are
no updates and there's no feedback loop
in case the model answered incorrectly
like where is the learning but we do not
want to start a discussion about what
learning means now we just wanted to
make the point that fuchsia learning as
we see it from gpt3 onwards is just
glorified pattern completion
now with palm in this few shot learning
setting there are six tasks where we can
observe a discontinuous improvement with
scale so a certain size where the model
suddenly gets it with enough parameters
with enough scale the capability of
solving logical sequences just emerges
is this understanding
i have no idea but with english proverbs
miss coffee bean would assume that
enough parameters are enough to memorize
the proverbs
no idea honestly i wonder if there is
anybody in this world understanding what
kind of understanding happens in these
models
we observe these discontinuous jumps but
do we really know why they happen
honestly no and speaking of emergence
and reasoning just look another
emergence from model scale and data
happens if one gives a reasoning example
to palm then pawn reasons too the
authors call this chain of thought
prompting
palm gets as input a question its answer
and the reason then for the next
question the model will follow the
pattern and give a reason to its answer
too incredible
following the same idea of prompting
where the output is a completion of the
given examples palm can also explain
jokes but keep in mind it can do so
because its input is an example of an
explained joke and a new joke
this makes the joke explanation example
in the blog post which was circulated on
social media a little bit misleading
because it omits to show the prompt you
decide how much cherry picking has gone
into these examples because we know from
playing with gpt3 like models that they
sometimes succeed incredibly
and sometimes they fail gracelessly so
be excited these emergent capabilities
are indeed impressive coming from a
slightly conscious i mean slightly
boring language model
but also keep in mind that there are
experiments in the paper evaluating
fairness and biases that highlight
several problems of the model
reinforcing biases and exhibiting
toxicity
there is a lot we do not understand
about these models like why do the bad
things such as toxicity keep happening
we don't even know why the good things
are happening
okay i mean we know that scales enables
the emergence of some key capabilities
in the model like we have seen with palm
and logical reasoning but in the open
questions of the paper we can also see a
discussion about a possible alternative
to sheer model scale which is the effect
of having lots of high quality training
data
so high quality data could be an
alternative to large parameter numbers
that's one take the other take that this
could also mean that palm with its
540 billion parameters would learn
even more from more high quality
training data so that we haven't even
seen the limit yet
what do you think about this paper
on the one hand the model shows
impressive capabilities but on the other
hand it's boring there is no
architectural innovation in it
but you can imagine that while we did
not see the model innovation just yet
now that google knows how to train these
things efficiently on
6144 tpu chips at once
we will see more research and innovation
with large models on text but also on
images video audio you name it so this
is in a sense just the beginning and
we're living in exciting times and i do
not even start to say how a little phd
student feels about this
i mean how do you feel about realizing
over and over again that sutton's bitter
lesson is really a thing and that
scaling up is the way to go
or at least one of the ways
see you next time
okay bye
[Music]
you